fill er up you're listening to the cat
digital network and now Tim Dylan is
going to have
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to Tim Dillon's
going to hell we are broadcasting from a
porch in Los Angeles California I'm here
with my friend Devin Costa nice to be
here again back at ya so you might hear
some noise in the episode a dog barked
you might hear a cholo a drone something
you know don't you don't need to send me
a message and let me know enjoy the
birds chirping enjoy the [ __ ] natural
sounds what do they call them on YouTube
what do they call the things that
ambient no ambient noises yeah yeah
people can't sleep cuz they hate their
life but if they listen to a waterfall
it's okay yeah if I just listen to a
soft rain yeah
wind yeah it'll make this loveless
marriage I've committed myself to not
even matter
ambient noise we're doing this on the
porch cuz the power at my friend's house
here in LA has gone out and it's a real
it's a real block party all these
neighbors who never speak to each other
under any circumstances unless it's
shared tragedy have all decided to
acquaint they're all introducing
themselves they've only lived two years
for the first time by the way I'm your
neighbor do you not have power too and
one lady came over nice woman woman I
thought it'd be funny she came to my
friend's fiancee and she said hey
neighbor how are you do you have a power
outage I thought it'd be really great if
my friend's fiancee just looked good hey
listen before we get into this you have
a green card do you have any papers I
just want to be I want to be safe yeah
and I just before we do this and not to
be offensive to you but do you have any
paper are you a resident alien or you uh
yeah that's it would be funny if that
happened it would be funny it would be
funny a joke why can't you say things
that are you know you can you can folks
I just got back from a little comedy
festival in Austin I was having a
lackluster set after
lacklustre set stone-cold sober while
navigating an array of human filth
stumbling around 6th Street just drunk
frat bros and tech bros homeless people
all white which is nice to see it's good
to see them struggle um
dirty filthy people in Austin Texas and
then just you know the badges cost
between four hundred and a thousand I
listen humbly so I guess there's people
in the audience
so I'm not gonna say part of it was me
you know yeah but I was I did a great
live podcast with Ron Bennington that
was [ __ ] great and then stand up on
the spot the show that Jeremiah Watkins
does was fun too but I don't know what
it was maybe I'm sick of some of the
material I'm doing or I just it wasn't
connecting with the people you had these
seven-minute sets you had to get on and
off the stage I'm a lot in seven minutes
yeah you know and people are still
sorting out what's going on right and it
was definitely not my best showing there
but I got to spend time with a lot of
other comedians agents and managers so
thank Christ
yeah that's at least the Silver Line
yeah god I got to spend quality time
with people in the entertainment
business because if not you wouldn't be
funny if it wasn't for them if I didn't
spend time with the great people of
truTV and others I don't know why would
get up in the morning right so it's well
worth it the lackluster sets the vacant
looks in the faces of people as I'm out
there yeah trying to get it [ __ ]
chuckle right um seven bestival you fly
out to do seven minutes can you do that
that's I don't know I've I believe that
comedy festival should be illegal and
I've said that I've been on record and
I've said they should not be legal
no music festivals no festival yeah
block parties yeah large gatherings
where people pay to have fun yeah should
go away yeah in my opinion yeah
I would still like to get booked at them
so if you're listening to this don't
take this is like let's not book Tim
yeah I'm just saying right whatever
organization is involved the fun is
but listen people had great stats I'm
not I'm not nagging anything I had a bad
couple of [ __ ] shows you need I'm a
[ __ ] I can't [ __ ] handle it yeah I
mean it just sounds like you're kind of
a little disillusioned with stand-up at
the moment yeah stand-up is great for
you know but it's also there's there's
something about some people love the
formulaic nature of comedy and I don't
love that as much as I love other parts
of it but I respect the craft of it it's
[ __ ] hard but like so to me sometimes
I like a live podcast especially at a
festival where these your comedy fans
and they want to see you stretch a
little do something different
um so you know I just there's a lot of
comedy out there man
I mean the first show in Austin I was
talking to the guy in the front row I'm
like what are you doing he goes I just
started comedy a month ago I just
started doing calm it automatically I
get turned off yeah I get a little
turned off yeah I'm a little disgusted
that that's what you're doing yeah you
know it shouldn't be I guess I should be
like yeah good for you man right but
there's a part of me you know what it is
that well you know that it just wants to
kill him you're sitting front row you
know there's a chance if you're in the
front row somebody's gonna talk to you
right especially somebody like me who's
done three jokes to stone silence I'm
gonna get involved with the front row
now because I gotta bail out I got two
minutes left let's try to get a couple
of chuckles or a cough so I'd get the
[ __ ] out of here
go back to my hotel go to truTV's meat
party and eat brisket and fart and burp
in front of people that could write me a
check on their network sit there and
have the meat sweats in front of a bunch
of executives that I should be trying to
please hypothetically
there's no better time to talk shop than
when you're yeah and brisket yeah when
you're throwing down brisket Marlboro
Reds in Austin but you know yeah who
gives a [ __ ] it was fun great time
thanks for having me great time happy to
be there thanks for having me you know
yeah were you supposed to go to a
petting zoo or something you know their
infinite wisdom has decided that it
would be funny for their social media if
comedians took Patrick pictures with
animals they're torturing by locking
them in cages and I'm not an animal
rights activist you guys know that I
like a rib eye I don't give a [ __ ] but
you know why do you have a chinchilla in
a cat carrier in the [ __ ] hotel so
that me and the Sklar brothers can hug
it for your [ __ ] Instagram why is
that funny yes and why do we have to put
the animal through torture like that why
do I have to see somebody holding a
lizard to think they're funny yeah I
said to the people at Netflix I go
what's the bit right because I refuse to
do it I'm like what is the big the
animals weren't miserable enough they
got to hang out with comics too yeah
it's like what what would the bit be
here that I'm holding a lizard like we
have bunnies
it's just fun now have you hold a buck
why why is it fun yeah and then they
look at you like you're insane like
you're the problem so I didn't do that I
did a fun thing which I hope to play on
the podcast where we had some fun some
of their stuff was funny
they prompted me with words you know
like pitch this show if this is a couple
of words pitch the show and that was
funny
and I had a lot of fun doing it so it's
not all bad this is the thing there they
have some good instincts but then
there's the petting zoo [ __ ] which
somebody brings up and nobody vetoes
that person right what is their thinking
with something like that for comic like
like with no idea behind other than just
comics handles it's a visual let's get
someone's attention people like animals
and people like comics who are also
animals maybe if we put them together
it'll be cute it'll be cute
because if someone sees me holding a
chinchilla they'll go watch my comedy
line upset if they can find it okay you
know you find easier a chinchilla more
people I think more people will go buy a
chinchilla then then go watch a stand-up
set after that what the [ __ ] do I know
you know I'm not a marketing wizard yeah
yeah you don't need a special password
to go see a chinchilla you know and I
made some jokes I go listen I know you
guys getting floated by Saudi royal
money I thought that was funny they
laughed they laughed those listen
they're not bad people
they get it they know it's funny but and
listen it's a job for a lot of them
somebody up the chain said let's take
photos of [ __ ] people with you know
uh [ __ ] bunnies and snakes and they
were like okay mm-hmm but I refused that
I refused the petting zoo segment I just
didn't have as much fun cuz I'm a
Content I didn't do as well as I wanted
to on the shows I love my friends I saw
some of them they were a lot of fun and
some of the other people I saw that I
don't see a lot I was like oh this is
nice to see them and then you talk to
them for a few minutes and you go yeah
this is this is enough and I'm sure they
feel that way about me right really feel
that way about me too so it's not a big
deal I had more fun facetiming you right
the police chase watching a high-speed
chase boy for three hours three hour
police chase in Los Angeles car drove
through a fence at a park escaping the
cops drove through a fence drove the
fence into the street then finally his
car got over the fence and just he never
touched anything else the rest he was
like a perfect driver now you grew up in
LA are there it's chases like this all
the time yeah a lot cause you cat like
in New York right you can't really do a
high-speed chase him in yeah yeah you
were saying that in New York they would
have just [ __ ] you know shot the guy
up it's comfortable in New York is so
miserable they will start hitting them
gonna die with their car right cuz they
want to be a hero right they don't even
care you'll get a nap
in New York before anyone knows it's a
chase yeah
but we're watching this thing and I
FaceTime you it's two hours into it two
hours in yeah two hours in I FaceTime
you cuz I'm riveted by a high speech and
it doesn't end doesn't end you're just
waiting for this ending and there's no
ending and what's amazing is that
there's always traffic it took me an
hour to get here from the airport
right there was no traffic how it was
unbelievable and the guy it was he ran
the gas tank
I guess down the [ __ ] fumes every
[ __ ] end in it and the reason this all
got going supposedly was that there was
some domestic violent situation right a
woman somebody saw him hitting a woman
in the front seat and then because they
were a rat they called the police
yeah cuz they're a [ __ ] you know and
I'm yeah there was really no no one had
any solid info on if it was an actual
domestic violence case it was just a guy
driving with his girlfriend in the
passenger seat right and the new zooming
drivers girlfriend somebody probably
thought that was illegal and call the
police
what's great is you don't usually see
the police work and when you do this a
lot of times the stunning level of
incompetence is amazing when you watch
them and also this is all covered by the
local news
you know like Fox 11 LA yeah yeah and
these dirtbags in Arizona these people
come right out of Community College and
they put them on [ __ ] television
doing local news talking about god only
to some if they're lucky is shooting
right now some local school board race
nobody gives a [ __ ] about and the chase
is big deal for them but then you got to
watch those [ __ ] riff yeah it's
brutal
it is so brutal cuz they making jokes
about like oh looks like he might get a
speeding ticket on top of everything
this guy they're trying to do [ __ ] yeah
cuz these people are all scripts yeah
they literally shouldn't exist unless
there's a script in front of them right
you know and and show these morons who
are quite proud of their job at Fox who
gives a [ __ ] and they're like this is
with Pilar
or whatever right here for Fox 11 and so
for a while there okay they start
running out of things to say very
quickly very quick and you start hearing
like the producers like they will start
apologizing going hey my producers
asking me to talk more I apologized then
they start telling you why they weren't
talking like I wasn't really telling you
don't need a running commentary it's
like a golf game it just shut up you
shut up and let it happen now we all
want we're watching this because we want
a crazy resolution we want this guy to
get it in a hail of bullets we want the
cops to get shot not fatally but they in
their legs and they all want to get shot
they all want to get retired on three
quarters pension they love all of those
cops were hoping they got shot in the
ass and could retire on three quarters
pension so they could sit home and read
Facebook status is about Trump
okay every cop I know is just trying to
get shot placed it so they can still
[ __ ] their wife and hit her and so that
they can still they don't wanna yeah so
so we're hoping that this thing engines
horrific Allah you know hail of bullets
and out of a movie the girlfriend keep
trying to get out of the car when they
slow down right and you see him holding
her back in but then later on they've
started to say like oh maybe he's trying
to push her out and she's staying like
she's like a down [ __ ] you know he ride
or die nobody knows or some you know but
he knows what's going on I went on in
the car and they're all trying to like
just you know they're trying to create a
narrative they're like this feminist was
abducted by a man who's all right
probably he's probably alt right he
looks Mexican but he's maybe always
probably white and tan is it George
Zimmerman in the car it might be George
Zimmerman we don't know we have reports
it looks like just then you have people
that are trying like people on Twitter
away n people on Facebook live or
commented stop and they're all debating
whether she should get out of the car or
not
yeah she's got her legs on the dash like
she's there like she's bracing for
impact getting her feet on the dash
and everybody's like you know like this
woman's honor this lady this newscasters
like you know a lot of the comments say
that you know if they were in a
situation like that they'd be fearful of
getting out of the car and they'd be
scared and she's like you know if I was
in a situation I got I would be fearful
and I'm like you should be in a
situation like that and I hope one day
you are okay I hope you have something
more interesting to talk about than
[ __ ] whatever your life is at Fox 11
I hope you're kidnapped so you have this
whole thing happening and unfolding and
so this is what I love this is what I
love by the way about we're watching
waiting for the cops to try to ram this
guy yeah to do this pit maneuver right
which will somehow stop him okay the guy
is getting on and off the freeway
pulling in the parking lots easily they
could have stopped this anytime hours
ago with some type of maneuver now
here's the rationale that the LAPD which
by the way as we know historically
guardians of life okay the LAPD the
rationale they shoot a Pokeball out of
your hand if you're jaywalking okay if
you're a black guy and you have a
Pokeball they'll shoot at your hand
so these [ __ ] are now apparently
they've now discovered God and they
don't want to potentially injure the
woman yeah doing the pit maneuver
who's like flipping them off whose flip
or whatever yeah she's like flipping
them off she's [ __ ] spitting at them
she's like leave me and my man alone you
know so here's what I think is hilarious
so instead of endangering the woman they
instead endanger for three hours the
entire metropolitan area of Los Angeles
everybody driving is at risk because a
lunatics going 80 miles an hour for
three hours he's driving on the sidewalk
he's driving the wrong way down the road
on the sidewalk but they don't want to
do anything to hurt his lady yeah in the
front seat so the people the innocent
people who don't know him because I I
feel for her yeah but she knows him so I
don't know her level of in
since maybe kidnapped her but I don't
know but so instead they're just saying
we'll just let him in danger everybody
right kids mothers children thought
anyone in a car it seemed like a new
tactic like the led got woke or so yeah
and they're trying it's called ratings
let's let this play out for three hours
because we don't have anything to cut to
and then they start towards the end of
like we really want to go to Empire so
we're gonna have to cut over to Empire
this doesn't end yeah they go it's Jesse
small that's last episode of Empire yeah
which is more important than this
pretentious woman getting shot in the
face so Jesse Smollett whose crime was
fake we're leaving this real crime to go
show you a guy who made up a crime
that's that's literally what the Fox 11
they said that yeah literally yeah
they're going to show they're like
follow us on Facebook live if you don't
want to [ __ ] if you don't because you
know we we assume a lot of you're gonna
switch over to Empire right because
you're bull brain-dead so you'd rather
watch Empire than a [ __ ] unfolding
situation in your community we know that
you'll switch off of this dangerous
situation in your community to watch the
final episode of Empire yeah so that a
pathological liar can show how good he
is at it on screen and it was just crazy
but I had so much trying to facetiming
you how long were you watching it
dude I was watching it for probably 45
minutes until you FaceTime me and it was
the same [ __ ] he was just he was all
over town driving on sidewalks driving
on the wrong side of the freeway at
points and what was crazy was the lack
of traffic it was la at like 6:00 and I
don't know it was like people went home
to watch it
it was a PSYOP it was I think it was
fake this was fake it was some sort of
spices actors yeah we're not even dude
they were over playing their hand I
could see immediately that they weren't
real the lack of aggression by the LAPD
was also I was surprised because they
kept driving up to the car to do the pit
maneuver yeah and then failing and then
like getting cold feet just backing off
yeah heading cold
pulling into into parking lots of like
Wienerschnitzel slowly driving and they
were doing it with one thing we know
about the police is that they love to
hesitate
you're a situation out before they go in
this was the one time to not do that
when a guy's going 80 miles an hour
breaking every traffic rule you could
imagine yeah no one gives a [ __ ] I mean
and I ended just so dude the enemy was
bad subscribe the ending he [ __ ] just
drives down the freeway going 100
finally pulls off at a 99-cent store and
just makes a run for it into the 99-cent
store it was kind of fun to see people
like scared running another so funny do
you remember what you said no dad oh you
were like this is the third craziest
thing that's happened at that 99-cent
store that day you know it probably was
and people are running out of the
99-cent store I don't even know if they
noticed he ran in no people run into the
night he was just running out because
they feed their entire lives they feel
hunted I've been in Ross Dress for Less
with no shoes on I feel haunted so
they're just running out he runs into
the 99-cent store I don't know to get a
shirt he leaves his lady he thought he
was getting gas right
he leaves by the way I was expecting
that was the next thing he they were
gonna let him pump his gas refill the
car because they didn't want to hurt him
like we don't hurt the woman we don't
want to hurt him we respect them
that's all women we respect everyone you
know so we're gonna let him get gas
we're gonna let him get a coffee let's
let him get a coffee if he wants let's
get him let's we don't want him driving
and tired if we don't want him to sleep
we need him alert we've been at this for
three hours yeah so he runs in the
99-cent store they have a little problem
getting them for maybe five ten minutes
and then he babe you're not even that
long they all go all the cops going to
the 99-cent store yeah how great would
it be you're shopping at the 99 cent
store and you just see all these [ __ ]
cops run in [ __ ] guns drawn like at
up point in your life you gotta say to
yourself it's time to I gotta figure
something out yeah I gotta move up but I
gotta figure something out here because
this is not let me tell you right now
but but yeah all in all and a boring
ending one of my friends standing thank
God no one got hurt at the end I'm like
how do you have my number how do you
even have my number no one got hurt
I wanted to see this guy shot in the
face head shots hail of bullets I wanted
to see him get out and two guns and just
start firing oh yeah at the LAPD yeah
just to see what those dumb newscasters
at Fox 11 would say yeah I wanted to see
him and his girlfriend like shoot over
each other's shoulders like what like it
yeah mr. and mrs. Smith Bonnie and Clyde
yeah just go nuts I wanted to see her
get out with a Z and start shooting show
that the anchors at Fox 11 who had based
his whole thing that she was his victim
they were like the true act of a
feminist is resistant yeah she is
resisting the police right now
yeah because what the police really are
are Guardians protectors of a property
owning class I would love to just see
like well it looks it looks to me it
looks to us here and we don't have a
perfect view but it does look like the
victim is now shooting at the police now
we can't say for sure if that and we're
sure there's a good reason that she's
doing that but it just appears to us now
she's making a gesture at the police I
think she's telling him to suck her
[ __ ] that's what it seems like
but she's gagging her boyfriend just
pulled over started to fog do you know
how much how hot I like how great the
[ __ ] has to be after you've evaded the
police for three hours just [ __ ]
[ __ ] her hard
she's into it she wasn't in the
beginning when she was getting beat but
you she's got to be impressed by him
evading the police for three hours by
the way if I was getting hit and the
dude hit me evaded the cops for three
hours I'd be getting wet in that front
seat I'd be ready I'd suck his dick the
third hour I just starts lobbing his
[ __ ] going hey this guy's [ __ ] beat
the whole city of Los Angeles just
[ __ ] jump around on his [ __ ] and [ __ ]
wouldn't that be great like the news
anchors being like it appears down we
don't have the best view it appears if
the victim has straddled the driver and
is now [ __ ] him again it appears we
don't know we don't know if this is the
case but form or limit from our limited
vantage point here from the helicopter
which has the land that get gassed the
helicopter no [ __ ] because that's on
the drugging around on E
they're like from the helicopter view it
almost looks like the victim has
straddled the driver and has her tongue
in his mouth but again this is probably
a defensive move for her she's probably
trying to slow him down
the only way she knows how with her
[ __ ] I want to tell you about our
newest sponsor wix.com ok wicks is the
place to create professional websites
there's a lot of people out there that
don't think they need a website and
they're dead [ __ ] wrong you need a
website it can't all be Instagram
especially if you're a business person
ok you can't have your business on a
platform when extra tis a photo of you
eating a [ __ ] hot dog you got to have
a professional place to put your content
you got to have links you got to have
maybe testimonials of people that have
used your services you can write those
up yourself no one really checks them
out nobody knows that Kathy from Houston
Texas is someone you [ __ ] made up you
could just say you know Kathy from
Houston Texas wrote it man before I met
Tim my life was a mess but after three
coaching
sessions whatever you sell and I don't
care what I'm saying is you need a place
to have all that information many of you
don't okay
Wix is so easy it starts from scratch
you can choose over 500 templates they
have the world's most innovative
drag-and-drop website builder it's very
easy text image videos whatever you want
you can use their Wix Adi artificial
design intelligence where you can answer
a few simple questions about who you are
and what you do an ATI will create a
stunning website for you if you want to
proof of what a wet Wix website looks
like go to Tim Dylan's TI MDI ll ons Tim
Dylan's going to hell calm Tim Dylan's
going to hell calm okay
there's no is in the Wix website cuz
some [ __ ] bought it and that that
becomes a holy Sh I don't know what the
hell that you know it's probably one of
you who bought it thanks every you know
thinks we're gonna go into some type of
bidding war for that no we'll just drop
is I don't know who bought it maybe it's
somebody else doesn't matter but I'm
telling you guys if you go to that
website you go drop down to the bottom
and you sign up for Wix they will give
you a great deal okay they'll give you
10% off any premium plan 140 million
people have used Wix I look at a lot of
people in the world I can tell
immediately if somebody has a website
immediately when I look at them
literally this is true I see people I go
you have a website you don't you have a
website you don't a lot of people that I
see that are struggling that are in
prison I could say pretty confidently
they do not have a website they are not
getting your content out there and
that's a shame and it said I look at
people all that my mother schizophrenic
lives in an institution doesn't have a
website is that the reason she's in
there I don't know but maybe
if she had a website a place to put all
of her schizophrenic ramblings she might
have attracted a fanbase she might be
live-streaming
she people might be sending her money in
the live chat answering super chats she
might have her own network of other
[ __ ] crazy people
she might be reading this ad right now
and not me if she had just had a website
and I'm gonna offer this this is a true
thing that I'm gonna do because I really
want you people to experience how good
this product is if you go to Tim Dylan's
going to hell calm and you scroll down
and you purchase a premium plan from Wix
with 10 and it's like 12 bucks a month
it's no [ __ ] money especially if you
need a site if you purchase this website
and you prove to me that you've
purchased it you can come on the show
for a few minutes easy we can have you
call in and you can tell me what you
think about the show you can tell me
that I suck you could tell me what I'm
doing wrong you can tell me what I'm
doing right you can promote whatever
you're doing to an audience of thousands
of thousands tens and tens of thousands
of people you can do that I will give
you three minutes maybe it'll go longer
if you're good but minimum three minutes
on air in front of tens of thousands of
people to promote whatever the hell
you're doing if you go to my website Tim
Dylan's
di ll ons going to hell calm go to the
bottom and it's also a great website if
you if you want to check out the show if
you want to check out there's a lot of
things I've thought on the website you
can see how easy it is to build a
website's a great idea if your comic and
you don't have a website it's a good
idea if you're an entertainment it's a
good idea it's easy and I'm telling you
if you don't do it you're gonna regret
not doing it because we'll give you time
on the show to do it there's a lot of
people out there that think they can
just float by without a website we're
all online now that's it folks you don't
have a [ __ ] choice get the [ __ ]
online now that's it
come in from the [ __ ] outside what
are you throwing a ball around with your
[ __ ] kid
that's over what you need to do right
now is get online and stay online okay
embed the links into your website of
your other social media then you should
be the only time you should spend with
your family is having is instructing
them how to go to your website that's
the only you should only interface with
people through technology that's the
future stop resisting it Kok stop
thinking that life's gonna be fun you're
gonna be on the lake it's enough of that
[ __ ] we're all going into the box and
we're staying there and you're running
around without a website old school
thinking you're some [ __ ] charming
relic you're not you're an antiquated
piece of [ __ ] that'll never amount to
anything because if people go online and
Google you insert you they don't find
anything you're dead if you don't have a
website you don't [ __ ] exist you're
dead oh you don't have an online print
you know comics used to say that like I
don't really have an online presence
you're dead you know where those comics
or no they're eating out of garbage
they're eating pigeons on the street
because they [ __ ] thought they were
gonna perform and cute little burlesque
theaters and it would be word-of-mouth
would travel people talk to each other
in the town square
nobody even leaves their [ __ ] house
anymore I've never seen a person leave
their home voluntarily unless the police
dragged him out of it okay so get online
and stay online it is healthy [ __ ] these
losers writing all these damn articles
always bad for your kids it's not bad
for your kids you know it's bad for your
kids sunlight my Aunt Mary died of
melanoma you know where you don't get
melanoma 4chan get online stay online go
to Tim Dylan's di ll o and s going to
hell calm go to the bottom click the
link buy the premium plan prove to me
that you've done that I check my
Instagram dm's religiously I check
that's the only way you're getting to me
I'm not letting you you're not giving
you
give me any other [ __ ] information
but I checked those religiously I don't
respond to most of you because you're
insane but if you can prove to me you
could tweet at me but prove to me that
you've done that you get three minutes
on this broadcast do it man I mean we
had so much fun that was a it was a very
fun time dude it was so fun but nothing
compares to the uber ride nothing
compares to my uber ride from LAX Los
Angeles International Airport to my
buddy's house I get into Ober I by the
way as I'm getting an uber LAX as these
announcements that they make with her
like we hope you've had a spectacular
experience in LA and I'm like who has
had a spectacular experience here and
then I'm looking at like other people's
parents kissing and hugging kids like
going back to college I'm like I never
had that in my life you know what I mean
yeah my mother gives me a kiss from her
room at the state-run psychic wars you
know psychiatric institution you know my
father would probably blow me a kiss
over FaceTime from a golf course he's at
but no one's ever dropped me at the
airport and said son go to set the world
on fire you know it's more like oh
you're in Austin now shut up so that's
sweet you know yeah yeah yeah that's
nice it's sweet
and some of those college boys I feel
like I want to just go up to them after
their parent and just also hug and kiss
them as they get onto the plane just
back listen I just want to wish you the
best of luck - and that's how you meet
people but I get in I get in the uber
nice woman normal woman yeah normal
person does not appear at all right to
be a little chunky she looked like go
always someone that could be a relative
of mine right okay yeah nah
slayed a decent car a nice new car nice
Chevy little car little SUV get in the
back
hey you got a charger hey Tim I don't
but if you have a cord I got a port okay
I got a cord this time I have a cord put
it in you know ten minutes I'm just
listening to some music she tries to
talk to me a few times so I said you
know what I like talking so I just take
the headphones off yeah and I start
getting into it with her we got I look
at the the phone we got 48 minutes 48 Oh
God so I seen her I'm like hey how are
you she's like good she's like were you
coming from one like Austin in New York
City should go you live in New York I'm
like yeah but I'm moving here I'm gonna
split time and everything she's like oh
that's cool are you traveling on
business I'm like well I kind of live
here you know my business and personal
it's kind of the same thing she's like
oh that's nice I'm like do you live here
she goes yeah I live here I live by
Englewood she goes I've been living here
six years oh that's great she goes yeah
she does I come from a little tiny town
in Florida called Perry Florida because
it's known for hunting just a cute nice
conversation and she goes you know I had
to leave she goes because you know how
small towns are you grow up you know the
same people they know you was one thing
but you want to be other things I'm like
yeah
I'm getting into it now right like I
feel that too yeah I feel the same way
as you do she's like you know I'm I'm a
goofball I joke around but she's like
but the reality is I'm not only that I
want to do other things she's like when
I was a young kid I was an actress I
went to modeling school and she said cuz
there's you know there's there's agents
in Florida in agent Florida but it's
hard to get one in LA I'm like the
business is [ __ ] endow me I'm like
it's all you don't understand I'm
getting going fifteen minutes may know
what I mean I'm like you know what I
mean I'm in now hardcore like thank God
I had this Huber driver what a sweet
woman trying to reinvent her South read
and you know she's talking about Florida
she's like you know I you know I was a
server in Florida I worked to the Olive
Garden like you like the Olive Garden
like yeah I was like I was always a
Friday's guy she goes Fridays with
always 45 minutes away you know she's
like I prefer to Applebee's yeah this is
a small-town girl from Florida from
Perry Florida she goes I'm working about
eight or ten hours a day she cuz I met
my boyfriend here she goes when I first
moved here i did move in a low-income
housing I'm like I get it it's [ __ ]
it's oh there's a housing crisis right
you know lie yeah let's go so I met my
boyfriend he was a security guard at the
building so we just started talking and
I invited him over one night to stay and
he just never left and I'm like that's
great you met someone you cared about
right she's like yeah and she goes and
we lived with his mom now you know we're
looking for plays I'm like that's you
know it's okay I'm like keep her happy
she's like I do I do errands for
whatever she needs she's like we think
we're gonna move to Vegas you know you
know because it's cheaper there and I'm
like go where it's cheap you don't want
to work she goes I can get a two-bedroom
for nine hundred like that's it's
because I could have my friend stay and
I'm like great this is great just go
listen you don't have to be wedded to
any idea of what your life is supposed
to be I'd love to start over in a new
place I don't know anyone
I just can't because I sold my soul to
this [ __ ] you know
yeah and she's like she's like I bet
you're really funny I'm like oh I'm
funny baby you know right and she's so
sweet nice J I'm going to because I'm
working extra hard this week because I'm
going down to Florida and I want to see
my friends so I want to make sure all my
bills are paid and I want to make sure
that I want to make sure that I some
extra money to spend when I go out with
my friends I said well that sounds great
and she goes I'm also gonna see my son
while I'm down there I said well that's
nice how old is he she goes he's 19 I
said 19 you know that's an age you know
what I mean yeah I said what's he up to
she goes he's gonna ease in a little bit
of trouble I'm like well 19 you know how
they are yeah when I was 19 I was a
hooligan I was smoking weed running
around not paying my bills license is
suspended I get it
what's going on with him smoke a little
weed getting a little crazy not in
school doesn't know what he wants to do
she goes yeah he's incarcerated right
now
he's incarcerated right now and in the
county jail he's been there about a year
Hey
was it drugs she goes well he just fell
in with the wrong people and I said
that's always the way it's so hard right
you can do now thinking about you know
she's talking about getting an apartment
for nine hundred and hagas I'm like what
things are percolating but she's so
sweet
yeah I'm like well she says sweetie this
is a woman she had a kid young it's very
hard the [ __ ] life is tough
yeah I'd look at the I look at the phone
we got about we got 21 minutes left
we're in the final stretch so I said I
said we're we're talking and she goes
you know he's incarcerated and my mother
visits him every other week his father
never wanted to be a father so he
doesn't really visit him and I go yeah
you know I said it's tough I miss what's
he in there was it like a fight drugs or
something the car goes silent I go I'm
not comfortable amount of silence she
goes rape it's a rape and I go I now
trying because we've had this very
positive conversation about life
affirming and moving and changing and
evolving yeah so I said oh she goes yeah
but she goes three of the girls they
already say their testimonies are
inadmissible but they're going with the
other two I said three of three of the
women she goes yeah because one of them
said he did it with a knife and that's
not Justin Justin wouldn't do that
Justin wouldn't put a knife to someone's
throat and now I'm in the Oberer and
we're talking about the Olive Garden
five minutes ago we're talking about her
getting an apartment in Vegas and how
nice it was she wanted to evolve and
explore who was in LA yeah and I'm like
so your son is a serial rapist at 19 and
he's been in jail for a year in Florida
she goes well he's got a public defender
and she goes she goes you know women lie
and I go I bet some do I bet some do I I
bet some
now I'm like am i on a show and I on
some type of thing where I'm gonna be
[ __ ] now so I'm trying to make very
cautious statements I'm like well human
beings are you know they're prone to you
know I mean it's yeah
because some of these these these girls
in line okay so so go and she goes
there's gonna be a trial soon I said oh
okay and she goes but he's in Polk
County in Polk County Polk County uh you
know it takes a while she goes but she
goes here's what I think happened she
does he had sex with two girls and then
she cuz I think they felt bad about it
afterwards and then they went and said
that it was rape but it was a you know
she goes it sounds like a threesome to
me so I said well you know I'm like oh
why did why not at the headphones in and
I'm like I thought it would be if it was
that time just put my headphones right
in and just but I'm like I'm in now I
can't get out so I'm like I don't know
what to say to that I go well you know I
mean he's in jail for a you're like that
sounds that sounds like there might be
something to it yeah you know I mean
again I'm not a law enforcement person
yeah but he's in jail for years because
you know they really drag their feet
over there and they only let them out
for an hour a day and I'm like okay so
we finally pull up to the house and I go
well listen I hope it works out she goes
yeah she goes
listen Vegas is cheap I'm like well the
other another I mean I know that you've
moved on from your son that I'm still
invested because I just met him ten
minutes ago and I hope that this works
out and she goes I should um I should
have had a move to LA with me she goes
but he's he's anxious he has anxiety
like okay yeah so Timmy gets his buddies
house and Timmy goes on the Google's I
said let me go on the Google I said I
wonder if I'll be able to find this guy
I said I wonder if I'll be able to find
this gentleman yeah say somewhere in
okay I said maybe I
won't you know I'm just gonna Google
Polk County rapist let us see what I
okay okay okay
Polk County deputies say they've
arrested an 18 year old serial molester
who's accused of raping and molesting
girls aged 12 to 15 12 to 15 to 12 year
olds to 13 year olds in a fifteen year
old his arrest affidavit say he snuck
into the girl's bedroom windows pinned
one down in a park threatened one with a
knife and threatened to take matters
into his own hands if a victim refused
to meet him it sounds like a threesome
it's cheaper in Vegas you needed to
leave a small town because you wanted to
grow as a purse your son is a serial
molester who's raping people at gunpoint
and you're talking about you're doing
[ __ ] [ __ ] motivational [ __ ]
self-help book [ __ ] in the car she did
tell me before I got out she goes you
know he was touched on his father's side
that's why I always tried to keep him
away from his father's side so this poor
guy and I don't mean that because he's a
demon but he was probably [ __ ] and now
he's raping him Eleni people but dude
you got to remember where this
conversation started her telling me I
left that small town in Florida cuz I
just wanted to realize my dreams yeah
and maybe my dreams aren't a career
maybe I'll never be a great actress but
you know what
I can really challenge myself and
discover who I want your son is a serial
rapist who's raping children and you
telling me that you want to go and do
[ __ ] I want to go back to school for
cosmetics I want to work on set because
I want to work on set too and makeup we
learned she goes I took a summer course
we learned a lot of stuff special
effects everything it was really cool
huh his son is holding
wives to children's throats in Florida
and you're talking about makeup that you
want to be unset because I want to do
men's grooming on set I'm like I don't
what is that even a anyway let's get
back to your rapist son who's
terrorizing a community and I read more
about him supposedly he hangs out
outside of the middle school
the sheriff's like this guy's a
terrifying dangerous member of the
community who needs to be like lock and
key right
and she's like he's was on probation for
touching a kid before yeah he got
arrested for this and she's like I'm
just tired of the small-town vibe she's
like you know people in the small town
they just they never see it for what you
can become I'm like this was a very
sweet conversation till we brought up
your son who's raping everybody in
Florida holy [ __ ]
what oberoi brown one uber one who bride
and I started I took my headphones as I
started to talk to her I'm like man [ __ ]
all these people that don't want to talk
to their uber drivers it's not right
right these are people you should talk
to them they have stories I'm a comedian
I'm a podcaster I I thrive on stories
and I was right but I was like why would
anyone want to put their headphones in
and not speak to another human being in
the car
yeah thirty minutes later we're talking
about this guy and I'm like where where
so I'm like you've been here six years
he's 18 six years ago he was what twelve
the dad doesn't want to be a dad where
are you is he what your mom yeah you're
out here taking makeup courses while
this kids running around in and out of
mental institutions right this is what
she said she's like he's been in a lot
of institutions
I was dude I was like [ __ ] it's
insane it was crazy it's like a Florida
Project mom yeah I felt like it was kind
of surreal yeah because she was so
detached
and the front part of that conversation
was so different right and right after
she drive me off I guarantee she picked
somebody else and she's like yeah we're
thinking to go into Vegas we're just
going to Vegas I hope that's how every
uber ride she does starts it's just a
little cheaper we just want to save
money we just need each other right we
just want to love each other it doesn't
matter that I didn't make it as an
actress I like doing makeup I like
people and I bet it for most people it
doesn't get to my son held a knife to a
12 year olds throat right and I had to
leave Florida God God I mean Jesus
Christ left at 12 but left well she's
been living here six years over six
years that the kids you know had some
time to not be a rapist I'm not gonna
say the guy's name but you can easily
google oak county rapist you know my
[ __ ] fans are gonna be leaving
comments on the [ __ ] page tweet with
Polk County hey man do I support you
that's all I need some cash digital
subscribers starting a GoFundMe for this
animal hey man 12 year olds lie kids lie
all the time I'm a realist dude it was a
playdate threesome yeah dude I mean I
was just like because she neglected to
mention she was pretty forthcoming but
she neglected to mention that these were
[ __ ] children yes climbing in the
window of people's houses like a [ __ ]
like Jack the Ripper I don't even know
if he did that I think he got people
[Laughter]
who's climbing in a window with a knight
people want to debate what isn't isn't
rape I'll tell you what's right
definitively climbing in a window with a
kitchen knife into a sleep oh he's
[ __ ] you choose to leave those
details out yeah you say it sounded like
a threesome really you think it's just a
survival instinct for her to have a
because I think she's disassociate yeah
I think she's split her personality's up
almost yeah I think like I really
believe dude the beginning of that
conversation
she was talking she's like you know just
small towns they really people put
limits on you I had to cut ties with a
lot of people that I knew right I'm like
it cuz your son raped their kids the
people put limits on you you know like
police yeah like a lot of people put
limits on you the coroner the medical
examiner a lot of people they just
didn't want to they didn't want to
really see me as the person that I could
be like a person who moves to California
and ignores the multiple felonies my son
commits dude I was [ __ ] dude
uber rides are not some people tell you
[ __ ] I'm telling you right now it was
that's my crazies uber ride
that's my craziest uber ride that I've
ever had yeah because here's the deal
here's what makes that so [ __ ] crazy
and a gun a lot of people I've listened
to chow and they say it sounds on the
show like you are smoking cigarette I do
not smoke I've never smoked all the
cigarettes in the videos are unlit or
they're fake cigarettes yeah okay
the sound of what you're hearing is a
cigarette is me person my lips and
biting into a pair yeah you got a big
pair of your mouth I got a big pair
there now
here's what makes that so crazy right
you meet people every day you probably
have interactions with them that are
very surface hopefully yeah
and behind certainly behind me if I
start talking about my I mean I nothing
compared to what this the whole thing
was right but behind so many people is a
horror that you couldn't imagine oh yeah
that and they're going on about their
life like hey hey right we can get a
two-bedroom for nine hundred yeah as
soon as I heard that I was so excited
for her right so good for you she goes
we got a friends over have friends over
like I don't have kids but I
imagine if your son was a serial
pedophile rapist you would not be in an
uber talking about she was talking like
a college girl who was just like I'm
just I feel free she said that she goes
California I just feel free you know
doesn't feel free Junior junior doesn't
feel free yeah um and it's amazing to me
that you open that Pandora's box and you
don't know what's in there people's
backgrounds and I guess she was just I
mean she's just a dummy that had a kid
when she should was she young
like the chip that she's in like she had
the cap and she was really young she
didn't seem old yeah well not super old
right
she had a youthful energy yeah you know
it's just interesting to me I would feel
like if your son was in that position
you as a mother would not be talking
about going to school for makeup right
like I feel like you would be maybe
she's so wracked with guilt that she
can't deal with it yeah because this
person is that ruining the lives of
other people right you're ruining the
lives of other people
she's talking about going to Florida and
she's working for extra money not for
her son's legal defense which listen I'm
not saying that you should be throwing a
lot of money at that case either but
she's [ __ ] saving money so what her
and her friends could have saltwater
taffy what are you doing cuz I want to
spend money with my buddies when I go
back down to Florida I want to spend
some money yeah when she said her son
was 20 I'm like you know yeah maybe some
Florida bum being a bum yeah I didn't
think he was it Vassar right yeah I
thought I didn't think he was where he
is and for why you think you think it's
like half people do that because it's
like a psychological strategy to cope
and half is just they're just dumb dude
gotta be but I will tell you this I was
really amazed at how hard she
and at the girls right she's like
they're liars and I'm like well this is
a pattern of behavior this is multiple
accounts but I was amazed that she would
tell the story as if he had been
railroaded right he's hanging out
outside of a middle school in the
article they're like yeah this is the
creepy guy that hangs outside of the
middle school and she's talking about it
like it's some case Elect mistaken
identity right
sounds like a threesome to me she's like
one of the one of them one of the
testimonies you know the girl with the
knife that caught her analyze and it
can't use her I'm like but there's still
was a knife to her and I bet there
wasn't a lively some inconsistency right
that you know for whatever reason they
felt was not beneficial to the
prosecution to use but she did say he
was touched on his dad's side it's big
but if I were her I would have I would
have said this this is what I would have
said okay I would have only said this I
would said my son is in Florida and I'll
tell you what he's not a stand-up
comedian he's not a clown he ain't doing
open mics and I would have said you did
a great job and I would have put the
headphones on and I would have listened
to a little Shawn Colvin or something
Sonny came home Shawn Colvin's got a lot
of dark music that this woman was
getting me in earlier some dark but
listen all the while hearing about that
I was so happy I wasn't eating brisket
with comedy executives how lucky am i
that I'm just in the back of the Chevy
hearing about child rape for an hour and
I'm not sitting in the lobby of a hotel
eating pulled pork listening to somebody
talk about their [ __ ] pilot
how long have we done I mean it is wild
man
I mean well they had that whole show
taxicab confessions right where cuz it's
based on I never saw this on that but
I'm sure the worship
she might be a recurring character of
that I mean I but it's based in like
that people in taxis they know they're
never gonna see the person again so they
get this extra level of vulnerability
where they're like I don't care I'll
tell that guy you know about like an
amazing point is that people and get
their does that podcast beautiful
anonymous Chris Gethard where people
anonymously call up and go into things
that they wouldn't go into yeah but it
is an interesting point you're in an
uber you're never gonna see the person
again yeah and I think enough people all
[ __ ] day it's kind of like free
therapy I mean even though she's not
doesn't see yes you just kind of unload
yeah on whoever's around and you're
probably the most into it all day the
most I got into it because I love
Florida and I appreciate a story that
takes a little bit of a turn I didn't
know where the story was going I didn't
know I knew it was [ __ ] when I got out
of the car right well when I pulled up
cuz I said this guy's a rapist in the
car is like just doesn't rapists when I
pull up the information he's a child
predator and it's really bad it's even
worse than what I thought and I'm not
trying to say that any kind of rape is
good but like the reading the whole
thing puts into context everything she
had said for the first 2025 minutes
which if you had heard the conversation
it was like two conversations because
the first 25 minutes was about a woman
who had to break break free of the
chains of small-town America and go to
another place yeah and work hard and
save money and get an apartment of Vegas
with a guy that she cares about in loves
and she she's a good person and she's
had a rough shot a few rough things but
you know towards the end of this
you're like man I don't know I mean I
know maybe she was a good mother um it
doesn't seem like she was great and it
seems odd to me that her so focused in
life wouldn't be to try to get this kid
to a place where he couldn't hurt people
anymore right you know yeah and maybe
maybe her leaving this all alone and
this kind of resolving itself because I
think he'll do time maybe this will be
you know maybe that's the resolution her
not investing herself maybe that's why
she can't go down there and really try
to spring him but she's going down there
to visit him and she's on the phone with
his lawyer she's you know dude it's wild
when your kid does something like that
yeah what do you
she probably yeah I don't know cuz it
she doesn't believe it but she might
secretly believe that he really is a
rapist and a bad person yeah so what do
what do you do if you're the mother of
AB dude I mean we'll seed do you ever
think about you think about how you
looking about having kids
sure yeah a little bit I mean the
nightmare you know because some parents
do everything they can
yeah and the kids still I bet she had a
rough road man right and I bet something
happened to that kid it's just the help
that that guy needs is so beyond the
scope of what most people can offer
you'd need like you know agent what's
your name agent Starling
you know what was uh what agent Starling
I'm not he was Hannibal Lecter who did
Jodie Foster oh [ __ ] I don't know her
name but yeah that's what this is yeah
you walk in you need a criminal
psychology you need somebody who is
truly educated yeah and like just it's
just one of those things that's he's not
gonna be solved in this lifetime you
know he
not gonna like have a he's not gonna
reform be able to be reformed I feel
like if you're that deeply twisted well
she told me she's like you know I knew a
teacher who kind of had some of these
problems who now has a normal life so is
like oh you know a teacher hooray who
can die for broke into Windows and and
now he's doing he has a normal life now
and so she was saying and I'm like yeah
it can happen I don't not bad it isn't
like yeah you know people have real big
problems right you know and um it was
just a wild [ __ ] thing it was one of
those experiences where I was like this
is [ __ ] crazy but like right before I
get out of the car I'm sitting there she
goes you're a comedian I'm like yeah I
said - I said listen I said listen
you're in the zubur all day right she
goes yeah I said I have a podcast well
Tim Dylan is going to hell and I gave
her the sticker the little Tim dill is
going to how stick her and I said listen
if you're ever bored because I'm bored
all the time I said I know your son too
but if you're ever if you're ever bored
give it a listen and if she's listening
right now I want to say listen ain't
nobody perfect please like please
subscribe leave us a positive rating on
iTunes and if you're interested in the
archives six dollars a month ain't a
hell of a lots of money to pay folks
Tim Villa county comm for all the dates
if you want to come see me live I'm
gonna be at laughs Boston at the end of
the month I'm dead crow comedy club in
Wilmington North Carolina May 3rd and
4th something like that at the end of
the month
Friday and Saturday May I think it's
17th and 18th and left Boston or 18 to
19th and left Boston June the 20th to
the 23rd at Mohegan Sun in Connecticut
the 27th I'm at side splitters in Tampa
we got more dates coming up in the fall
I'm gonna be in New Jersey I'm gonna be
in Vermont I'm gonna be all over the
place I'll be in LA full time starting
in June so I'll hopefully be out here we
are making the announcement folks we are
going to two times a week I'm gonna have
to take more overrides to fill the
content but you know daddy will more
overrides more stories more felonies
twice a week get on board now please
rate subscribe review the podcasts
follow me on instagram tim j dylan di ll
o n on twitter same handle Devon what's
your social media youtube.com / Devin
Kosta dvan co sta and Instagram Devin
trill Kosta and listen to my podcast
hate the 11 with Devin cost on iTunes
Devin is a [ __ ] amazing comedian he
does videos that are hilarious do a deep
dive on Devin's YouTube get his YouTube
channel go watch his videos you'll fall
into a rabbit hole watching them they're
very very funny check him out watch
before YouTube deletes all of them yeah
you think you're gonna delete I don't
know they're getting weird they they're
they're they're muting weird parts of my
videos sometime really but your videos
are not I know that's why it's getting
weird like I don't know who knows I will
say this though go to those videos
they're very very funny
Devin helps us with all the videos that
we make that are that are up on my
Instagram and we're gonna we had a lot
more should come you have a lot more
content coming we're going to a second
time a week on the podcast we're also
going to do more Instagram videos we're
doing more content we're gonna set up
something and this is gonna be a little
while but we're gonna set up something
where we're gonna offer and this is not
gonna be you know immediately this is
gonna be down the line we're gonna
really try to create a platform where we
can get you content and videos directly
to you things that are funny things that
you guys [ __ ] like and that is what
we're trying to do now that's where the
business is heading that's the future of
everything we just want to make funny
[ __ ] that people like if they won't let
us do it on SNL or if they won't let us
do it on other networks we're gonna
[ __ ] find a way to do it we're going
to
find a way to get it to you guys you
know all of that is in the works and I'm
watching other people guys like Andrew
Schultz some people that I respect
who've been able to really get his stuff
out there with [ __ ] no help from
anybody yeah so that's the direction
we're going in so if you like this [ __ ]
it makes you laugh it really helps us to
just [ __ ] rate review I know it's
stupid but get it out or tell your
friends about it because that's it it's
you guys basically spreading the word
anyway that you can because the reality
of the situation is you ant you're not
gonna hear this on a network right
really unless things change thank you
folks